c'était une petite chance au cos animé
fagnes
un marcheur munich et llosa mans classic
ou la nuit kamau mag et chaque clic
chaque nuit chaque nuit je me trouve
j'ai mes tours toujours en difficulté je
trouve comme cissé qui mettait pas assez
mais reviennent encore gisele est une
survivante
c'est comme cela qu'on appelle les
femmes qui vivent à la maison d'orka
[Musique]
on
les apprennent ici à surmonter leur
traumatisme
en chantant en dansant et en
s'entraînant l'espoir aussi mail aussi à
fortifier les muscles des faso qui est
une fois un quelqu'un de mauvais qu'elle
me reprocher je peux aussi mais mais
sauvé embarras et à un moment mais aussi
les body un jour à la brunante
l'adolescente par couper du bois dans la
forêt
cinq hommes la poursuivre je cours et je
courais fortement en garde à la
plantation mots ils m'ont losc est ici
je vous lis mais sauvé pour sauter un
arbre jeetoo mais il a aussi un arbre et
qui m'a entrer ici
il monte me il mot commencé à mes
batailles mais à m'intimider à
m'intimider
après comment il commençait à me violer
beau et d'une manière sexuellement
après avoir passé la nuit inconsciente
dans la forêt gisèle réussi le matin à
ramper jusque chez elle
là elle subit une autre forme
d'agression chez moi ou maltraitées
forte m'a vraiment ou maltraitées ou le
montrer comme quoi j pas l'air en forme
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à maman elle a
dit qu'elle n'agit pas je ne suis pas
parti et n'a pas cherché des bois mais
je suis parti chercher des hommes à la
force
une troisième suis senti très mal son
mano mais un goût tôt et nous titre
acquis en compte
je pourrais maîtrise ibm et iwuy
mais qu'est-ce qui a fait que tu veux
l'a pas fait qu'est ce qui t'a donné la
force de continuer bon il a aussi beau
d'aller d'éliminer toutes les personnes
n'étaient pas haïr quelqu'un
neuf mois après le violent jce elle
accouche d'une fille qui meurent à la
naissance gravement dépressive une
soignante la réfère au docteur mukwege
et le chirurgien qui a traité des
milliers de femmes violées depuis 20 ans
du coup on a constaté que notre action
médicale physique lorsqu'on associés à
la prise en charge psychologique donc la
santé mentale des femmes sérénité des
boues et qu'elle avait beaucoup plus de
force
esseulé mais pierre chancel et flers ça
cela compte ester l'une des psychologues
de la maison d'orka explique comment il
débute une thérapie avec une nouvelle
patiente et puis si c'est la ligne de
vie depuis la naissance
mais dans les fleurs vous présente les
événements et ray et aussi les pierres
elles représentent les événements
malheureux favoris gagnent les pontiac à
maribo seulement trois roses
pas de fleurs pour la naissance de sa
fille née il ya cinq ans à l'issue d'un
violent et beaucoup de pierre dick est
ici et là un suivi des viols
c'est pourquoi aimer une grosse pierre
et les viols accompagnés avec une
maltraitance dans la famille mari est à
nouveau enceinte encore déçu de viol
c'est une patiente qui avait déjà un
plan de se suicider et l'été menant à la
recherche et des l'hôpital où elles
s'entraident et synthé ou déposer son
enfant
et puis elle partira les metref et sa
fille
oui oui mais ni à sanaa
qu'on y met un goût non
[Musique]
la guérison passe aussi par
l'apprentissage de métiers
[Musique]
survivante après d'affaires des
vêtements des paniers du pain des
savants les femmes retourner dans leurs
villages ont invité le docteur mukwege
et à venir voir leur succès tout le
village au lieu de les appeler des
femmes violées le village les appelait
les femmes savons tous que les femmes
sont intégrés et que nous pour être sont
puissantes
non madame michu dans un musical docteur
mukwege sur et des naissances est aussi
fier il m'a aidé à passer que ma tête
soit soit posée et aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il sait qui a beaucoup évolué c'est
qu'ils les femmes brise le silence les
femmes de nans les femmes prennent le
courage même d'aller en justice
je pense que ç'a vraiment c'est ma
première étape vers la victoire
[Musique]
pour l'instant gisèle apprivoise
l'ordinateur elle veut apprendre à
naviguer sur le web et à parler anglais
ou via mail
les minimes et est il pour un visa à
l'université pour gagner soit il joue
aussi une dépité une députée oui
pourquoi vous fera aussi pour sauver les
pays ainsi avoué tous les moindres
recoins du mans à bercy